اذا بين تاكيد اوكرانيا ونفي روسيا لاسقاط
صاروخها المتطور امس وعدم وجود طرف محايد
على الساحه تبدو حقيقه الامر غير واضحه
حتى الان نتحدث هنا عن الصاروخ الاسرع من
الصوت كينجال يعني خنجر باللغه الروسيه
وهو احد اسلحه الجيل الجديد للجيش الروسي
كنجال صاروخ باليستي يطلق من الجو وهو ما
يتركه مع وقود اكثر للاستخدامه للوصول الى
سرعات اعلى وهو من نوعيه صواريخ جو ارض
يمكن ان تصل سرعه هذا الصاروخ الى اثني
عشر الفا وثلاثمائه وخمسين كيلومترا في
الساعه الى
12,350 كم في الساعه مع قدرته على حمل
رؤوس حربيا نوويه او تقليديه نبقى على
الارض في اوكرانيا التي اعلنت اسقاط صاروخ
كنجال والوسيله منظومه صواريخ الامريكيه
التي تسلمتها اوكرانيا الشهر الم طبعا هذا
موضوع في اشكال كبير وليس مجرد خبر
المنظومه تعمل بنظام دفاع متعدد الطبقات
اي بامكانها اطلاق ثلاثه انواع مختلفه من
الصواريخ الاعتراضيه المصممه لتدمير انواع
مختلفه من التهديدات كالطائرات الحربيه
والمروحيات والصواريخ والمسيرات التحليلات
تشير الى ان اوكرانيا استخدمت
طراز باك ثلاثه من الذي يمكنه اسقاط
الطائرات المعاديه على مدى حوالي 65 كم
والصواريخ البالستيه على مسافه 35
كيلومترا وفي ظل غياب معلومات مؤكده يرى
خبراء ان ضرب صاروخ كنجال روسي بصاروخ
باتريوت صعب ولكنه ليس مستحيلا لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه والاشت
راك في زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات